day one under taliban rule in some ways
it's really different from what we were
told it was like in 1996. i was with a
camera they're like yeah take any
picture you want and they were even like
posing you know like
taking their guns and standing a certain
way and like making sure that they had
their hats on correctly and everything
so they're trying to be very
accommodating and people were coming up
to them taking selfies
the turkish bakery has this outside
seating and there were the talib guys
just sitting there you know looking at
their smartphones and then also like
women there's not a lot but there are
women out some are wearing the chodali
the cortical
some are just dressed normal like just a
big head scarf loose fitting clothes
that cover their body
the police are missing there are
checkpoints like the actual physical
checkpoint but no one there to man it i
mean the taliban say they're the system
but they just arrived
you know like what system
people are trying to take out
essentially all of their money so banks
are running out of cash their atms are
running out of cash if you need money
say for medical care or for
transportation like transportation to
medical care that's impossible or if you
need money for food you know it's going
to grow more difficult i went to a store
to buy water and the the guy before me
he was complaining that the flower
prices had gone up by something like 20
30
so these are more like basic everyday
things that could become larger
humanitarian issues and also because
there aren't proper systems right now
who is the government who is the mayor
of kabul right now a lot of stuff is
just up in the air right now
[Music]
you